touring's a huge part of your life
crowds laughter
when are you going to get back to it is
it starting to open up now right
are you going to get do some uh indoor
shows soon
yes uh actually the comedy store is open
now
limited capacity and i have to tell you
after a year
of doing shows outside and dealing with
everything from mosquitoes to
helicopters to doing shows near
like highways and stuff to actually be
inside
and there's no distraction i went on
stage i felt like i was on steroids
it was so it was so easy like i built
back up my hellroom muscles that i used
to have
when when you first start out as a
comedian you basically do stand up
wherever they would let you like i went
to a long time ago me and this buddy of
mine richtelia did a show
at the uh the fisherman's feast in the
north end
in uh in in boston and we were so
excited
that nick's comedy stop called us like
one of the main clubs and we were like
oh my god we're in we're in and it was
like an
afternoon gig he was standing in the
streets after like there's a band
playing like bullari
whoa and all these italian women like
hanging out the windows like
i felt like i was in like the pope of
greenwich village or something
and we had to go on up after that and
just absolutely just
bomb like that's like the whole first
eight years of your career is like every
third gig
is as bad as that so after you
make it and you start selling tickets
you actually get
worse you're not as good because people
you
rather than having to get them they're
there's they're like yours to lose
yep and i kind of built that stuff back
up again so
i don't know how long that'll last but
um i feel like it's gonna be
an ex first of all like a renaissance i
mean i could be
i know it's not in either of our nature
to be optimistic but
i keep thinking people have been so many
performers have been put on ice for so
long yeah
that there's all this pent up
frustration observations
anger and it's all going to come out in
the arts in some
great way yeah i'm hoping it's going to
be a uh
a positive thing i don't know i just
wish they'd get rid of cnn and fox news
and the ability to leave a comment on
the internet and i think if they just
did that everybody would kind of relax a
little bit more
and it could be more sort of uh you know
you're on this side of it i'm on that
side and sort of give each other [ __ ]
and then
enjoy each other's points more so than
uh
you know all the capital letters that
people typing and [ __ ]
yeah um because i am all over the map
though i get [ __ ] like during
uh i get [ __ ] that i'm a trumpster i get
[ __ ] that i'm a socialist i mean it's
literally
all over the map but you make both sides
angry
i guess that's what i do i never looked
at it that way yeah it's a beautiful
thing
all right no one's happy when you're
talking yes
i think that's going to be my wife's
ringtone
that's going to be your new ringtone all
right uh you can see bill
in theaters across the country this
summer and fall on
big bur sorry on
what you can see bill
you can see bill in theaters across the
country this summer and fall on
bill burr the tour when i later have a
degenerative disease they'll say that
was when they knew
that but i mispronounced that right you
get worried that it's already coming on
i do i do too yeah whenever i
mispronounce something i think oh that's
when it begins
this is now now i've seen movies and
like a week later i can't remember what
happened
it's kind of cool because i can watch
him again
i've always wanted a place that will
give me an operation that destroys the
part of my brain that's seen godfather
one and two
so i can see it again from them again
for the first time
yeah that'd be cool come back again what
if you had that sorry did i not give you
the reaction you wanted
no you looked horrified which is
appropriate can you imagine if i had a
big scar right here
and i was running a fever all the time
and you said what happened i went i had
a part of my brain that i've seen
godfather one and two destroyed
but it also attaches to my my speech
center well no
when my brain went it was like well
there's drugs you can take that will
destroy that part of your brain and
everything becomes new again but i don't
know if you under even understand the
context of it i've been watching a bunch
of uh
and listening to a bunch of movie uh
music from the 70s and movies from the
70s
just simply because that's when i was a
kid
and i feel like that's before uh
whatever happened to me happened to me
and uh and so i go back there not like
that was the greatest time
i came over i came over listening to the
dirty harry soundtrack yeah
it's wild you feel like you're going to
go solve a case
there's some then there's this weird
woman's voice going like
like this weird sort of drugged-out wife
i know exactly that i know that i know
that soundtrack well yeah yeah so
i uh by the way one of the most uh fun
things
i've done uh just you know the last
couple of years was you called me up
when you were playing the forum
and yeah you said come on down i have a
drum kit and i'm with some musicians and
you i'm before i do my show at the forum
we get to screw around
in this amazing space so i came down and
you said bring your guitar and we had a
blast you're a great drummer it was
really fun
oh yeah thank you that was great that
was really fun comedian but i i uh
yeah we had uh dean del rey michael
devin i'm trying to remember
the people we had a mix of comedians
yeah failed musician comedians
yeah and like real deal uh guys like
michael plays
uh with everybody playing like white
snake and all that stuff before all this
crap
you could play everything yeah it was
great yeah yeah so there's a clip i wish
i could
if i could find it on one of my phones
we did uh van halen
ain't talking about love and there was
some guy who had like the van halen like
tribute guitar and he
you know was crushing the solo you came
down would you play van morrison
it was such a great time i think i
played van morrison yeah we ended up
playing for like almost it felt like
three hours and i had such a good time
and then when i stood up i had no energy
left and i was like oh my god did i just
blow it
you got to do this yeah i have to do the
show but fortunately the
the fear of screwing that up
becomes like adrenaline yes and i was
able to go out there um
and uh yeah i forget what that sounds
like even having like a crowd
so right we'll get back to it yeah
hopefully back to it yeah
all right let me make sure i get this
all right you can see bill in theaters
across the country this summer and fall
on bill burr the tour for full
tour dates visit billburr.com and the
mandalorian of course
available on disney plus massive
conglomerate
no one here is getting that money bill
burr
that's great thank you